I have been doing content writing for
about 5 years now and trust me it's not
an easy as it looks as a Content writer
there are lot of challenges from start
to finish youve got to really know who
you are writing for and make sure your
content is right for them your writing
should be short clear and in good order
and don't forget to keep your writing
style friendly and the same throughout
but it's not just about writing as a
Content writer you also need to make
sure your content works well on search
engines check and fix mistakes a lot and
keeps it unique and you have got to
listen to what the client says to make
it better it's tiring making great
content that really helps client takes a
lot of time sometimes you run out of
time and the quality of your work might
not be as good making you less
productive but here is the good news
today I am sharing a quick trick for
Content writers that saves times boost
creativity and productivity and keeps
the quality topnotch I am introducing
top five eii tools for Content writing
in 2024 but before we begin if you are
an aspiring content writer and want to
learn the best content writing
techniques in the industry to e your
digital marketing career then you are at
the right place introducing p post
graduate program in digital marketing
which will be your all over companion
with this program you will not only ace
in content writing but also keyword
research search engine optimization
behavioral marketing campaign management
social media marketing and much more
with these technical expertise you will
also gain complete Hands-On learning
with the tools like Google Keyword
Planner chat GPD Google ads Google
analytics and there are more than 30
tools in the list result reserve your
seats first and run now from the link in
the description box and pin comment
before we move ahead with top five AI
tools for Content writing consider
subscribing to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us so let's begin with top five AI tools
for Content writing on number five on
the list we have is wrer wrer is an AI
powered sentence completion tool that
enables you to create high quality
original content within minutes it smart
features in includes language auto
detection so you can create content in
multiple languages its AI is powered by
gpt3 that will help you to create
content that compete with professionals
with this smart editor you can write it
in clear tones that will immediately
connect with your target audience right
here exists in both free and paid
versions you can use up to 10,000 tokens
in free version while the paid version
starts from $19 per
month just go to wrer doio log to your
account find the settings where you need
to choose whether you are a single
writer or you work with a team or what
is the main motive of yours to uh use
this tool once you are done you can see
this screen so this editor provides the
feature of either sentence completion or
you can also create the complete data or
the article or anything whatever you
want to try so right now let's as we are
already talking about the content
writing let's take a small introduction
of what is content writing with using
the writer.
iio let's start by knowing what is
content writing and once you click on
the completion you'll get the small
intro about content
writing yeah there you go so we have got
a small introduction about what is
content writing like this you can create
whatever ad copies or you you need to
create an article or blogs or whatever
kind of content you want and from the
right side you can see there are certain
settings where you can choose the
languages a language for your writing it
may be UK English or us English then
grammarly you can use it the tone can be
formal or informal and the creativity
and everything the length of the content
moving to number four on the list which
is copy. a copy. a stands out as a
versatile tool that enables content
teams to boost their output by 10 times
without compromising quality with an
array of 90 plus tools and templates it
guides user through the creation of
diverse content including blog post
landing pages payer click PPC ad copy
social media post and much more copy. a
is available in both free and paid
versions you can create content for free
up to 2,000 words per month
however with the paid versions there is
no word limit and it will come at $149
per month so just log to copy. a web app
and where you'll get an option of chat
so we are already here I have logged in
and I have got certain again I have got
certain uh options to choose whether I'm
a just I'm working as a single content
writer or just choose whatever option is
for you and just click on the chat so
here we can get all the requirements uh
it is again the generative kind of stuff
which we are getting with the copy.
EI so let's take an example to write a
copy for a social media post for perfume
brand so here I'll
type write a social media post for
a for a
perfume brand
name super
perfumes
let's
[Music]
see let's try if we can get another more
options from
this let
provide two other
versions and let me tell you this what I
using is completely free of cost so yeah
you got a number of versions here
and from this even if you have certain
points to be included you can just make
those changes in this um chat section
and you can get the change version of
above
versions the next tool on the list is WR
Sonic right Sonic is gaining popularity
in the list of AI tools from past few
months a perfect place to create long
form and short form content so get
content ready write the best blog post
SEO descriptions product descriptions or
any web content needed with WR Sonic it
includes multiple features like it carry
out plagarism checks maintain brand
voice that makes it One-Stop solution
for Content writers right Sonic is
available in both free and paid plans
free plan includes 10,000 words per
month however the paid version starts
from $113 and go as high as $1500 per
month log to the right Sonic account
using your Google or any email ID once
you log into to WR Sonic you will get
the number of things like library
history you get number of other uh WR WR
Sonic apps like audio Sonic and chat
Sonic and you can create content using
those also they also provide uh image
generations and text to
speech uh even the generative AI using
chat Sonic you can write an article or
create your own document let's try to
use the chat b or the chat Sonic and
write
Sonic
create an article on what is content
writing let's
see B is working to create an article on
what is content
[Music]
writing you can see that within few
seconds we got a article of very good
words
length and what I can see from this was
it looks completely SEO optimized with
the keyword content writing and it
covers almost all the possibilities of
content writing like purpose of content
writing we get the types of content
writing like blog writing website
content we are getting social media
content copy writing technical writing
and definitely they are not just
providing about the content writing but
skills required to become a Content
writer or skills required for Content
writing the next tool or number two in
the list is writer writer the another
widely used content writing platform
famous for its short form content
features if you are looking to create
content for social media product
descriptions emails for marketing and
sales SEO meta title website copies and
much more then yes writer is your
perfect companion writer is available in
free and paid versions free version
provides 10,000 words per month while
paid version starts from $19 per month
to use this web app you just need to log
to the writer account and you will get
the option to create a copy to create an
image and to create a chat so let's use
a
chat so let's try to create content for
the very first perfume we have
used write the
homepage content for the perfume
[Music]
brand also writer also provides the
facility to add or edit the already
created document you can do it from the
new document feature here so here we can
see we got a very good length of content
which shows and uh describes in detail
about a perfume brand you can
additionally add any of your points to
cover if anything is missing or if it is
required by a client or any changes any
addition any
relation here I'm using the free version
of Writer
app at number one we have Chad GPT Chad
GPT can assist in content creation by
generating ideas expanding drafts
providing editing suggestions answering
queries aiding in creative writing
suggesting language enhancement and
offering basic translation services it
is available in free and paid versions
Chad gbt 3.5 is available for free
version whereas gbd4 is available in
paid
versions as we know chat gbd is the
widely used tool and I'm here using chat
gbt 3.5 which is completely the free
version for chat gbt uh G pt4 is the
paid version as we discussed earlier
first we try to write the Facebook ad
copy for the perfume Rand
so
[Music]
WR Facebook
add
copy
for perfume
[Music]
brand perfume Dr
named
super super
[Music]
perfumes within few seconds we got
almost everything for a super perfumes
brand they are covering the website link
they adding the hashtags and
everything
just completely add
optimized so here we wrap up top five AI
tools for Content writing covering the
best free tools used by content experts
do give it a try and let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below if
you find this video informative do like
it and share it with your friends stay
tuned with us to stay updated with the
latest industry Trends till we meet
again thanks for watching watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here